[Music]
so James has prepared these slides for
me so a couple of things happen in the
preparation of the closing notes just to
explain the concept to you typically the
closing notes that PI data for the last
two years have been given by the chair
of the event without them having seen
them ahead of time and that's usually a
joke we can make fun of we're on video
right we can take some really mean
things about em when I was going up now
because I don't want to be recorded
however have you ever had a really
simple task like putting together a
couple of slides and then you got caught
on a small technical problem and I've
wasted all of your time that's basically
happened to me
here so I want I want to especially tank
to people in the audience that made what
we're about to do possible this is very
high concept and very difficult
technically we're going to do twitch
plays closing them there is a link here
on bitly it's a Google Doc that Google
Doc has 26 slots in it as you fill in
these slots they will appear on the
screen we will construct the closing
notes for Emaline as we go now I filled
in a couple of things which you might
want to choose from so if you want to
open this up we will play twitch plays
closing notes give us a second so let's
get that going and that's the game
so which PI data and I want to thank
Thomas Cleaver for helping putting this
together and Alexander here as well who
are helping us put this theater so this
is our first slide as we put startx into
that it'll appear on the screen
okay so I should wait a minute or so
there we go bitly slash twitch - pie
data in the black next to Friday but
what shows up on flight oh hello
so okay thanks the sponsors all very
good right well of course events really
aren't possible without someone putting
up the cash to pretty much to do them
one of the one of the big things we get
is a venue and catered with Bloomberg
and they have been a huge thing for us
in that it allows us to run such a
fantastic conference such an amazing
venue which itself contributes to the
atmosphere to have so please for them to
have come forward our regular man AHL
have come forward to the gold sponsor
this year they sponsors all throughout
the year as well so it's very generous
on top of that coming to go do that they
they sound like they were very pleased
with being here thank you ever so much
together at the booth good and all this
is distracting and yeah so thank you
very much for okay four words here we go
as always as sponsors for a very long
time a thank you very gently sponsor our
conference thanks so much for coming
along in dava simile sponsored last year
thank you ever so much as well and
Cawood spark as well as their first time
thank you to you and to also Ralph or
speaking for us later something on early
this afternoon
and of course Oracle as a new sponsor
for us thank you very much for sponsors
a big round of applause for them all
[Applause]
and of course you can't make a
successful conference and sponsors don't
want to go anywhere let's be but there
are shots go do it
I've always extremely pleased with how
many people you know give up their
weekends come along we know you've got
busy weeks as well and you come along to
basically take on more work and we're so
pleased that yeah quite right exactly so
it's all you saboteurs out there who
decided that this is a game this is a
game there we go yes what do you sleep
out there on the t-shirt to file yeah
quite right I think you've had enough
fun on that slide oh yeah that's exactly
what we did we showed you smoke puppies
or puppies and thanks Bobby quite right
well the thing is you can take a filter
and a player over any other image to
make James is I don't know with you've
seen James been that guy everything
symmetrical right it's always the the
systems obviously glitching so imposter
syndrome is a real thing and I don't
suffer from it so I've got the opposites
so I've got enlarged ego problems and
it's like it know if I get in my head so
impostor syndrome is real thing and we
deliberately design the kind of
inclusivity of our conference so you
should never feel like the imposter
being here we deliberately set the
content to be really hard to understand
so if you come away not understanding
you know but don't feel too bad
basically this very much we can say
other of the Neman in pain faces but yes
slide F slide F oh and of course thank
you thank you very much - don't focus as
always - being the background sponsor of
all this they give us a really good
reason to put on a conference and have a
lot of things and the stickers I mean
you know you can put them on your fridge
you can put them on your clothes maybe
maybe you have to wear a suit tomorrow
and you're thinking how can i
accessorize but I'm not allowed to wear
anything that jangles off me because I
work nearby fans yes so I've been told I
have a keypad of things so the people
they are so Leah you saw Lynn you might
have got an email from shields a lot of
the invoices Savannah help put the
conference together we thanks very much
for that
jean has been here doing a lot of the
diversity and she's the communication
director none folks she can see us now I
can see her staring at us there you go
wrong way everyone wave yes hello
and where's Christmas well yeah since I
came to see you okay kind of a kid maybe
looking out of it
I'm needing new glasses thank you me now
as well always very good will we send
their emails and she gets back just nice
and quickly la me know now we need to go
back already
okay we'll give me a second thank the
committee oh yeah yep see you the
committee was it's a chaos together oh
no this was a yesterday one day okay so
the speaker so yes thank you - a lot of
really the organizers - who helped us
really out as we can
[Applause]
mr. lamarka stood in the audience with
coffee around posted around the friend
Marcos over there as well some still
kind of like running around with their
heads almost falling off because I've
been so busy o that we can do go up to
some of them and just you know give them
a little thank-you and so on and we do
we'll do this as a voluntary basis and I
can't react sighs that an ass like you
come home from Alexei and you end up
doing another three hours of playdates
left so it gets very very busy okay how
do we go back down oh go forward okay
thank the speakers the keynote yes we
had a huge volume of talks which
proposed then about 180 odd that were
proposed which three of them would
adverts they were really used to get rid
of but the rest were pretty much golden
so thank you ever so much to the
speakers who spoke today and for those
who maybe apply for a tour but didn't
get it all but still culinary Thank You
long you know first point in the
community and yeah we just hope that if
we thing gets bigger that it yeah if you
run a legacy system and you haven't yeah
buddy
this thing's where I think gets nutty oh
yeah I can yep what's that right so of
course we sign up with full fact in the
morning and we thank them very much of
being here have a very busy time but
arguably there was a lot given back in
the hackathon and thank you everyone who
took part of that will Moy was was the
the speaker for full fact and meeven
babacar who spoke as well they were you
know they were inspired by how much
stuff got done in an afternoon
especially since a lot of you guys know
a lot of NLP and oh that's right gene
Hogan did his visual arts dude I think
thank you very much to him he all put us
to shame with how much work he gets done
just bear in mind that is actually a
full-time job so all of those all of
their open source stuff that he does
he's doing that full-time and the only
way supporting himself is through his
workshop so if you ever want to go full
term and please co2 monitors workshop so
you
plan a pull request and fix one of these
bugs that maybe haven't noticed yet
lovely and we had we had day to come
this morning that's where I'm at rats
Commons in here and also Charlie
Harrison preemption they give a lot of
talks morning thank you very much for
that to round off our section of
keynotes a big flak for the keynote is
for coming on and doing that Unger I'm
going to bed right I'm gonna know some
of you know this I have two small
children I have a six-month-old son who
wakes me up again
the hokey-pokey isn't the hokey-cokey
it's hope you poked a bit more Jabby
you know I'm just checking whether if I
break the law it's okay because I've
been told to break the law I'm going to
I'm going to say no on this one no so we
go any more flight coming I'm going him
yes okay all oh yes do vote for the best
tweets with our results good that won't
laughter excellent there is a prize to
stay around for that but yes don't slack
channel don't ones in there to vote for
or get your submission in and do a bit
of social media foo and get people to
vote for it that will do as well there
are stickers and t-shirts last for those
of you are so you know there's all
t-shirt to the back so you shouldn't see
really when our also giving away some
orange t-shirts on a very SS confessor
so on exactly when I look at this
can you can you can my life you cannot
walk in a bar without people looking
exactly exactly right
contour conga line of one that's
impossible and conga line to the lost
and found
I'm impatient when it is so we just go
around an infinite loop so I'm going to
do a bit of control and see in terms of
awesome sounds actually if any of you do
have a sand found then please do first
desk we write it down write down the
whole email
I don't know that Condor lineup and file
picture okay I like it someone's
someone's trying to hack the slide
presentation by throwing in a PHP script
thinking maybe they haven't secured
against an injection attack we have you
get you can see you can see for the fact
bellowing in ampere sounds next slide
it's not oh it's not a smell bad
they were stage please health and safety
really Oh health we can't get everyone
on say
Victor's of health and safety that's
what they're saying volunteers thank you
very much for the volunteers you come
through and it's it's it's a simple
bargain we asked them to come we happen
to show up come along if we give them
what we get to work for the whole
weekend
you know what I'm actually didn't uncle
cheesy the buzzers showing up didn't
they know I'll see you right you're also
to show up like they don't have to do
anything but I thought the ones you did
turn up we're suppose fixed positives
talk about one who's actually if any of
you are interested in volunteering to
the meet house so that you reach out
there yeah oh sauna
no that's sorry I'm talking slightly
cross-purposes they're quite right sorry
organizing committee I don't only go one
needs to volunteer in it Oh volunteering
for that oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah if you
if you want to help organize this thing
you can definitely come along it is a
lot of fun the yeah actually that's a
complaint but yeah we definitely need
summers and sub-branches so if anyone's
ever willing to maybe start like a fight
a Guinness
maybe people sorry we're going to stop
you there I want to thank myself for
coming along
and you're welcome and thanks Oliver
coming along
cheers God thanks making them you know
nepotism event that's quali I promise he
did pay for a ticket but family that's
why we had loads very little kids and
stuff that was good ah should have a
[ __ ] we did consider doing like fresh
support dimly and unfortunately like
right now because of allocation or the
crushes are closed on weekends
it's kind of bad part about it so hello
no it's not alright alright planning of
families is that that motel get requests
nurse don't I don't know when those
stops pop codes when attending in the
Cochran what that is
pop quiz II we go these were the pub
quiz winners well congratulations to
these people tougher them this this pop
quiz instead of mind-bending code
samples and lots of trivia about the
numbers organization so no surprises but
this charming lady knew some of the
answers and they win by any time was
that one surprise it was that cucumber
it was amici come up the asking we
deliver that on the cake on this so it's
really slide so I have to get rid of
that with that and then oh if you won
the scavenger hunt what is actually I'm
sorry what it is no no your professor
elicited I don't know it's one of those
things where maybe we shed with it
didn't a sign of on have all year
someone is someone from the logins or
something and he won he won the
scavenger hunts
let me know what you what does he win
I'm saying everyone he had that have
what he was you win free dude if I dated
next year okay yeah
right congratulations bout the whole
thing out
did anyone else feel the whole thing out
how many well some initiatives work some
initiatives go right right tell people
oh yeah okay so the pilot of the meetup
if you can get past the weightless is an
amazing like lollipop for a very select
elite few I mean another another
advantage being a committee member is
you are guaranteed a place yeah and the
remuneration is basic we are the bestest
all right it may be the fastest ones the
way frappe although really an outside
picket either we're trying to the next
date and time yeah old a next event
right the next event is coming up next
month yes we have about 500,000 members
which is pretty good we we put on a
couple hundred months which is still
going biggest thing you yeah probably
well to be honest I mean right things in
the world watch carefully I go strictly
in here be well yeah I've got yes well
this is what those unfortunate cases
were to compare it to no one else we are
the biggest by default which has been
number one which if you try to move yeah
I know we should just wait until they
can split the whole lying speakers get
ready good no that's fine that we're
ending we're ending here that's perfect
thank you very much right so lighting
speakers to be wit ready who was who
sign themselves on that sheet that's to
come speak that's not just iPad be run a
machine
good so over here that good anybody else
there were 11 people eight me 9 10 11
excellent right point you'd like to sit
in something of a row then I'll sort you
out in a second
good I hope you'll have fun
is that one's good in order order look
okay I think we should sit in high order
a hairline order yes you have I sorry I
think that's the best kind of order love
stops oh hell hang with me howling so
I'll call about we'll do it right so in
fact if we can get Chris howling
crystalline lovely if you wanna come get
yourself set up that would be grand
thanks emblem Oh what about really move
it I think I can catch that one should
we go back I have a blue tail thanks I'm
in two years so we were wondering
whether the still thank you can men yell
yeah yeah that's good I would I would
dispute that
I explained to meaningful access on see
I I said I think we're just going to say
that's one lovely juicy something it
thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]